this year the Academy's Board of
Governors presents its honorary Oscar to
a man whose work is vitally important in
the history of American film he was the
master of a new kind of psychological
and behavioral truth and acting the work
that he did and the actors he used
brought a thrilling new reality to the
stage and screen
more than anybody he inspired us he
taught us a new respect for ourselves as
actors and the potential power of our
professional profession the passion of
his performers matched his passion to
explore the suppressed but raging
discontents of our civilization at a
time when the prevailing American voice
was bland and glib this poetic realist
this angry romantic always spoke
fervently to almost basic conflicts
between races and religions classes and
generations men and women here are just
a few moments both heated and tender
from a lifelong lover's quarrel
conducted which is with his adopted
country by a ferociously gifted
immigrant named Elia Kazan
ladies and gentlemen mr. Elia Kazan
I thank you very much I really like to
hear that and I want to thank the
Academy for its courage generosity and I
want to tell you that I've been a member
of the Academy on and off for I don't
know how many years so I'm pleased to
say what's best about them they're damn
good to work with I also want to thank
Marty what are you wearing away Jaime
Jaime go ahead where's Marty thank you
Thank You Bobby
Bobby DeNiro okay
okay thank you all very much I think I
can just slip away